guys are getting injured too frequently
in philly but if they could ever get
their best 11 on each side of the ball
they're a force to be reckoned with and
if it happens this year they're going to
be one of the last teams standing in the
nfc uh i i don't disagree with much of
what you said there i'm not sure i'd put
them in the top three or four but yeah
definitely like dancing around that top
five six you're right when they're
healthy added to the fact we saw a
quarterback who
we we now know and then listen i already
knew but i hope the rest of the public
knows he can carry the team on his back
that's special it's special if the play
fails the players fail whatever it is
philadelphia can rest easy and go yeah
we'll still be able to create some
offense because we got this big freak
number 11 cars and wentz back here so
they have to be excited about that and
you're right injuries decimated them
last year you know i think so much of
the coaching staff you know jim schwartz
a d coordinator doug peterson the head
coach the offensive coordinator they got
a great way about them a great energy as
a football team and the industry the
injuries you know led to their
destruction last year as far as them
having to fight through some tough times
and barely get into the playoffs but i
do think
they've really since the super bowl to
now
have done a phenomenal job of kind of
reorganizing their roster you know it
wasn't like a rebuild or anything like
that but they flipped a lot of positions
have some new pieces in there and mike i
think even to your injury point or
injury point have covered their butts a
little bit this year with wait if desean
jackson gets hurt
we can't let that happen again it ruined
our offense last year oh wait we drafted
a jalen rieger oh wait we signed a
marquis goodwin jr you know in free
agency right uh so he opted out but he
opted out so he's not there but they
tried to cover their butts with that to
go wait we don't need to do that we
don't need to change our offense now we
have enough moving pieces so i do think
offensively you know that they're going
to be better this year but they need
alshon jeffrey healthy and they need the
rookie jaylen rieger to show up and
their defense i'm excited about that too
because we'll get into it they've made
some big moves there on that side of the
ball
and you know they're one of the teams
that i pegged when we did our antonio
brown draft the teams that should or are
most likely to sign him i could see the
eagles developing an interest in antonio
brown once he gets through the first
eight games of the season the suspension
ends and he's available if they have any
injury needs at that receiver position
and we saw last year what carson wentz
did with a bunch of guys we didn't even
know who they were all due respect i
don't remember who they were after they
they stepped up and got it done but it
was once his leadership that made it
happen and and this eagles team i think
if wence can stay healthy again
and if he can stay healthy in the
playoff game and it was an illegal hit
from janevian county that wasn't flagged
he wasn't fined it's still amazing to me
that there was no consequence for that
hit where he went in hot helmet down and
and concussed carson wentz and knocked
him out of that wild card game
if wence can stay healthy and healthy
into the postseason this is a team that
can do
a lot miles sanders currently injured
has a week-to-week lower body injury uh
yeah and and
they've got injuries on defense they've
got injuries on offense they but they
always find a way and they seem to play
best when their backs are up against the
wall it happened in 2018 it happened in
2019 it would have been very easy in
2018 just fold the tents hey we just won
the super bowl we don't need to try to
scratch and claw out of this hole last
year could have been very easy both
years they have that resolve they have
that will and they are dangerous in
december and if they could go into
december with a better record this time
around that's when they could maybe
separate from everybody else and be a
really good team i got a pop quiz for
you all right pop quiz time yeah
who was the eagles leading receiver
during their four-game winning streak to
clinch the division title last year
chris okay all right well i feel like
all right there's two names right away
that pop to my mind i think is are you
tricking me here so because it's either
it might be a running back it could be
boston scott but it could be greg ward
i'm gonna go with greg ward because i
don't think you're trying to trick me at
805 eastern time in the morning
i don't know the answer pete does pete
what is it
dallas goddard right dallas goddard 252
greg ward 209. boston scott so you got
two of the top three you did all right
there thank you thank you well you know
i mean but there again
you know just speaks to hey i want we
need miles sanders healthy if you're an
eagles fan you need him healthy i think
running back position is you know
lacks an explosive guy other than miles
sanders in that offense so i think he's
very important but i mean the tight end
play i mean it's real here in
philadelphia i mean it really is it's
you could argue it might be the best duo
in football i haven't thought about it
much but as i sit here and just talk it
i think it is the best duo in football
so again if they can keep those
receivers healthy and i think that's
what's cool about you know jalen hurts
and jaylen rieger because i think jalen
rieger again doug peterson oh andy reed
school of coaching he's got his he's got
his tyre kill now here he goes you know
whether i like
jaylen rieger is a first round pick it
doesn't matter he's gonna be that guy to
me speed sweeps goes screen routes
things like that stress the defense out
and do all that and then jalen hurts you
know again i wouldn't be shocked if we
saw some sort of taysom hill package as
the year went on to where he might run
throw option whatever it may be but i
like that added element to their offense
that was you know already pretty good
but to have that element to keep
defenses off balance and the
trickeration and things like that it's
just going to make their base offense
even better this year
and by the way you mentioned that word
trickeration i had somebody email me
yesterday to say that's another sims-ism
that we are giving him a pass on
trickeration is a word that's been
around football for a while so this
isn't a chris you're right
it's part of the football
dictionary you're right yes yes it is i
i didn't come up with that word out of
my own stupidity that was something i've
heard my nfl
[Laughter]
yeah i just want to be clear because now
here's what happens
there's two levels of the simsism game
level one is noticing the things that
you say that are made up words flowing
from stupidity and then
my stupidity in not catching them in
real time and calling you out on them so
i get emails pointing out that hey you
idiot you didn't notice what the other
idiots said you're both idiots yes so
that's the new game it's not just your
made-up words it's my failure to spot
your made-up words but just
the the person who asked me about
trickeration yesterday it is an actual
word at least in the football dictionary
maybe not merriam-webster all right
let's rank the weapons for 2020 by way
of receiving yards you mentioned jaylen
rieger we've got desean jackson al-shawn
jeffrey zachertz dallas dallas goddard
how do you make them
fall in order based upon how they're
going to produce well i i still think
zach ertz is going to be the guy that
leads the team in like receptions right
like he'll still get the most targets
you know probably have the most
schemes around him and carson wentz has
a comfort level and throwing him the
ball you know after that
you know that's where it gets into the
dallas goddard alshon jeffrey
conversation i think second there
uh as far as who's that next guy to
accumulate stats but i don't this is the
beauty of this mike i mean it's hard to
rank them because
i i just think they're gonna be by
committee it's not gonna be that type of
thing we're gonna look at one guy having
oh he's got 1300 yards and the rest of
the receivers and tight ends are all
around three and four hundred yards no i
think what we could see is like al-shawn
jeffrey around 700 yards desean jackson
around 700 something yards you know
jaylen rieger around there as well with
god you know with with earth sporting
with a thousand and goddard having six
or seven hundred yards that's what's
going to be awesome about them you know
that's to me when an offense becomes
really damn good is you go we can't pay
anybody to anything we don't know where
the ball is going what formation they're
going to get in we have no idea and they
have a lot of guys that can cause some
problems there so you know i don't know
i know that kind of i copped out of that
answer but it's i don't know that well
it's tough
i'm going to take a different path here
i think one of the reasons why we're
having a hard time ranking these guys is
we have to factor in the injury yeah it
is it's tough take into account the
possibility that it's going to be
somebody not even on the board right
that ends up making an impact because so
many of these guys get hurt and our good
friend vince the cowboys fan who reacted
very negatively to our comments about
dalvin cook last hour because he
believes we should be clamoring for cook
to walk out of camp because we were very
pro ezekiel elliott hold out last year
he chimes in saying the eagles start the
season with two dinosaurs at starting
receiver and jackson will get hurt again
like i tell all the eagles fans what did
you make it through 10 plays last year
dinosaur well that dinosaur can still
run and we saw it week one last year
against washington when they were down
and i spoke to carson wentz after that
game it was desean jackson providing
that spark yeah and we got a glimpse of
what he could do and chris i was all
over the eagles last year
carson wentz stays healthy start to
finish this is a super bowl team the
problem is he's the only one who stayed
healthy jackson it was that following
sunday night i think it was the falcons
game yeah a little cameo appearance
something's not right and he never right
away he was back for like one little one
little appearance where it was obviously
had to get surgery and shut it down but
if there's a way that they can find his
33 year old frame which is not a very
large frame to stay healthy he could be
spectacular for that team and if it's
not him maybe it's someone else because
what carson wentz did last year with
that roster they threw together on the
fly when everyone was injured it was
amazing and that carries over does it
not chris did that confidence that you
get when you get it done that four game
winning streak to win the division does
that not elevate your game how you view
yourself how others outside the team
view you and you bring that into the
next season definitely yes he's coming
in flying high feeling like hey i'm the
man and whatever the circumstances are
i feel like i can lead us through this
tough time and and really to me the big
thing
would be and of course we've heard you
know some of the rumblings going into
last year about you know carson maybe
not being the best teammate and leader
that way not like nick foles and and all
those type of things well i think it'll
go a long way in the locker room too and
the team and the the players there to
just go
you know man whatever we thought about
carson wentz he's the freaking man for
what he did at the end of last year and
that'll make him you know
he'll be viewed at a different light and
i think the coaches and everybody did
that already but yeah i think there's
something to build on there and when
they go back and watch film this time of
the year of last season they're gonna go
damn look at some of the things carson
once did
and we didn't even have our starting
team out there so that's where it's
special you know and really offensively
if they can stay healthy yeah it's it's
a big thing we know that yeah desean
jackson john jeffrey are dinosaurs but i
do think they have a little more
insurance
behind them this year at least to where
if they are banged up the offense won't
be in the spot it was last year uh great
offensive line we didn't even talk about
them and they lost brandon brooks but
thank god they got jason peters they
move him to right guard and their first
round andre dillard's out there and we
haven't even talked about their defense
they had a top 10 defense in football
last year
right mike and they got javon hargrave
and malik jackson's coming back and they
signed darius slay you know yeah they
lost malcolm jenkins but they signed
some other guys will parks and things
like that so i just look at the eagles
to echo what you said early on ago this
is one of the better teams in football
with one of the better coaching staffs
and a top 10 quarterback and that's why
they're dangerous
i'm very intrigued by what darius slay
will do at the cornerback position for
the eagles given that
they essentially stole him when you look
at what the rams gave up to get jalen
ramsey i understand jalen ramsey is a
better player than jerry slay but two
ones and a four with no new contract for
jalen ramsey is what the rams gave up
when you look at what seattle gave up to
get jamal adams i know it's a different
position in the secondary but it's still
the secondary
the eagles got darius slate from the
alliance for a three and a five they
signed him to a contract that isn't over
the top tremendous market value it's a
fair contract for both sides
uh you know they may have something here
definitely just because he wears the
eagles helmet now i worry about him
getting injured but let's assume he
stays healthy what does he do for that
defense well he finally gives them this
shutdown corner that they really have
not had i mean you know this has been a
little bit of an issue for their
football team they've been trying to
find guys to fill that corner void for a
number of years you know yeah they got
ronald darby you know they drafted the
sydney jones kid from washington he's
never been healthy so you know to me
this is where jim schwartz will be able
to get creative too because now he's got
a guy to go wait i can play man with you
and do all crazy things with these other
guys and feel comfortable with that
match-up uh so that that's where he's a
game changer let alone if they have a
very deep defensive line to go along
with it where you just go man this is
another thing where you go if they stay
healthy on the defensive side of the
ball they got size and speed up front on
the d line you know corner play with the
darius slay is to another level now you
know the only only area of concern i
look at their defenses go linebacker a
little bit you know there's some
unproven commodities there uh but but
you know it's hard to have a perfect
roster
yeah and uh they are moving in that
direction i think you're right the depth
is more of an issue this year it's more
of a concern it's more of a focal point
you want to be better prepared for the
inevitability of the injuries and the
injuries have already happened for the
eagles in training camp best case worst
case philadelphia eagles 2020 chris what
do you got well you know we're in the
state of pennsylvania we did pittsburgh
yesterday i mean the absolute best case
i i could see the eagles in the super
bowl there's no doubt i mean they're
just too many game changers on their
team for not to be able to think of that
let alone you know the meat and potatoes
of their teams pretty damn good too with
a coach that's aggressive and all that
what what
in it or win it
i'll say win it i'll say win it i think
they can win it beating andy reid
wouldn't that be a super bowl and the
chiefs
his old team would be unbelievable it
really would be uh but yeah i mean i i i
think they're in that class of a
football team certainly and then when
you say the bottom or the floor what's
the worst case scenario
man i mean
just missing out on the playoffs but i
just think within that division you know
i look at washington i look at the
giants and go there's four games if the
eagles are healthy they should win all
four they're better than the giants and
and washington right now i know it's the
nfl and it's not easy to say but worst
case has like barely missed the playoffs
i don't think it can get much worse than
that
worst cases and a rash of injuries
including carson wentz because there's
no nick foles on the roster and i don't
know that jalen hurts can step right in
and make a difference as a rookie nate
sutfeld i know they really like him he
missed all of last year with a wrist
injury that he suffered in the preseason
but i i don't have faith in the
quarterbacks because i haven't seen it
maybe i could change my mind but worst
case would be wence gets injured and it
just all falls apart for the eagles
because they don't have somebody who can
come in and get it done and the way
wence plays that risk of injury is
always it is going to be there all right
let's take a break what's your best case
you think they can go to the super bowl
i bet
i think they can go to the super bowl
i'm not sure they can win it but i think
they can go there it would be one hell
of a super bowl if it was chiefs against
eagles i don't want to just hand the afc
championship to the chiefs i think the
eagles would have a hard time with
whoever the best team in the afc is
unless somebody sneaks through
like you know when the patriots knocked
off the dolphins in 85 only to get
killed by the bears yeah two weeks later
right something like that would set it
up for the eagles but the best that the
afc has to offer i think the eagles will
have a hard time so i can see him
getting to the super bowl not
necessarily winning it and the worst
case for me
wheels come off if once gets injured in
six and ten type of a season maybe five
and 11 but uh here's hoping that doesn't
happen and the eagles can get back to a
level that we've seen them at very
recently
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports